[Music]
in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Nathan
and Rachel are with us hey guys how are
ya we're good Dave hurry great little
nervous
okay we've never lost the patient you'll
make it we'll get you through
oh that's reassuring well how many four
million people watch this every month on
YouTube no press a little uh it's
probably more than that but it doesn't
really matter
thank you for take a million what's it
matter you know me you're gonna it's
just you and me
hang out we'll just just be you and me
but you got the green on where you guys
from Tuscaloosa Alabama all right so you
substituted the Crimson for the green
today well st. Patty's Day holiday yeah
there we go
all right very cool and here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off about two hundred eighty thousand
dollars Wow how long did that take
it took about 19 months whoa this is
scary okay and your range of income
during this time we started about 63,000
and we're up to about I don't know two
shy of 110 I think okay since those
numbers don't work I'm assuming you sold
something large like a home yes we just
moved to Tuscaloosa about six months ago
so part of that was a home know called
our home in Pennsylvania what do they
sell for 275 that's all for 2005 and we
had some equity in it that we used to
kind of pound out the rest of the debt
right and of course the 280 includes the
mortgage that was paid off you sold that
we owed 215 on the house and so then
about 80 $100 of the cars that we had
was really nice honestly that was just
that I loved and I had to warn to depart
with somebody how dark and then about
55,000 and student loans within the rest
of the mortgage Wow okay so you guys
really leaned into this we'd also
coordinated it with a move so why the
move was a job change it was a job
change okay so what happened 19 months
ago this started your on this process
it's it's kind of a funny story my
younger brother Danny his birthday happy
birthday Danny he keyed us onto this and
because because he had gone through us
to you and he really enjoyed it and I
just thought well this is strange
but I listened to a couple of episodes a
couple of podcasts and as the weight of
the student loans really started kind of
it was heavy and I thought you know this
this desktop stinks I don't like this
and and so I started listening to more
and I really kind of felt the wisdom of
what was going on and so I started
talking to Rachel about wanting to sell
the van oh that's a good idea that's all
yeah we were there so your van honey
yeah well I was I was as patient as and
genuine as I could be I was really
concerned that the van was was delaying
our ability or he would get rid of the
student loan debt
it was the log jam for us and it took a
while and we finally came around to it
was probably where your part comes in
yeah so I wasn't too keen on the I think
we need to sell the band yeah I think up
something off of that entree yeah I
loved this man but he it was about a
year where he came he never came it was
always with love it was always it was
never in a nagging way it was never
every day it was not every day it was
just you know every few months or so I
think we need to sell the van is keeping
us from making student loan payments and
about a year later after all this kind
of was going on this conversation I kind
of have a little awakening moment
spiritual moment and she came home that
day and said I think we need to sell the
fan yeah really what a great idea and it
was a complete 180 yeah yes what
happened anything in particular you
could point to I mean you know it's just
I think was um I think I just need to
come to the realization mm God really
touched her heart mm-hmm it was just a
moment I can't really explain it a
federal Superfund
that's fair elder no troubles good well
congratulations you guys Thanks
so thank you then you took another job
and moved that was a part of the planner
that just happened in the midst of all
this well yes and no we we were already
you know we did everything we sold
everything that wasn't nailed down as a
matter of fact our cat died in the
process and no mother going around
telling people we sold okay
and we sold one of your colors mention
about selling four-year-old their
four-year-old toys to get out that we
sold our four-year-olds toys to get out
of that didn't get us all out but you
know we just sold every so much stuff we
actually counted a little while ago we
went and just looked around and looked
under every Rock for opportunities I
mean yeah we I donated plasma we had
jobs just everything we could just to
scratch and hack away at this and the
final shoe that drops though is the move
right well that's the interesting thing
we weren't really thinking about a big
move until this journey kind of started
and we realized the income isn't doing
it for us started kind of looking around
we had a jobs we didn't need to look
desperately and and this job fell kind
of into our lap and it was it was a
miracle that that it all worked out and
it for me what at what mattered was the
fact that that we had done the work in
advance when you talk about that alone
that you know God helps them that help
themselves but they really need to say
God helps them that help themselves
first mm-hmm and that made a big
difference because because the move was
important and and it just sped us right
up and and it's great because now this
is one milestone that we we have done
and and never have to go back and we
have so many more goals to achieve then
we now can even faster Wow very cool
well congratulations you guys what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of it is and we practice we rehearse
this on the way up here we know you that
so some of the reasons I do it over and
over is to let people know what's coming
yeah well you don't get surprised well
there's some standard answers but for us
we had to get on the same page first
right you you can't be equally yoked if
you're not yoking or if you're not
pulling in the same direction and so we
had to get unified and then and we had
to sacrifice and dig deep and just stick
to it
remember mowing the lawn one day and I
was listening to a one of your podcasts
and and and you said you know some
people say well Dave I don't know if I
can do this and what you said was well
that's probably the only thing that will
stop you and I listened again and again
and again because that was before most
of the miracles happen
and I honked I clung to that and it
mattered it made a big difference to me
because my determination only grew
stronger Wow one of the successes for me
though or keys for us to get out of debt
with the always stay tuned and to your
team here because when I did have my
moment of okay we need to sell the van I
would I was talking to someone who I
thought would have been a great support
in this decision and they admired our
goal of getting out of that they just
questioned our sanity of how intense we
were doing this and why would you sell
van that's crazy that's an awesome car
so she calls me in tears at a conference
and and I said you know you really
should listen to Dave Ramsey they have
these debt-free screams and about one
out of three they talk about how I got
called crazy all the time yeah so that's
when I actually just youtube do and I
saw a bunch of the DEP three screens and
I was sold
game on I just keeping it on ever since
but staying tuned in and then we went
took a few but we also coordinated a
couple SBU classes well not helped us
just keep for me support myself around
people that were willing to well there's
nothing like all nothing like teaching
something to make you do it for sure
yeah I mean doing going to class is one
thing but when you're leading it like
hypocrite City if you're not doing way
to go you two very proud of you and you
brought your daughter how was she her
name age anything and where me is that
how much she has caught on with all of
it very very got her the financial peace
junior kit and we thought I'd take a
couple months to catch on but he okay it
was clicked like a week just right there
perfect you shine you changed your
family tree then that's what you've done
well we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's
book to celebrate our much fired and you
can let the next chapter in your story
to be millionaires planning out rageous
generosity and Bill wealth that's a
night game on game on indeed way to go
you too very proud of you thank you
alright Nathan and Rachel and Hannah
Tuscaloosa Alabama 280,000 paid off
including a move the sale of a home and
an odyssey nineteen months it took sixty
three two one ten count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three three two
one yeah that's how it's done that is
how it's done right there man that is
awesome this way to go you two
very well done well so when are you
going to do it he's right what we say is
true that sometimes the only thing
stopping you from doing is believing you
can when are you going to get control of
your life this is your chance people
this is your chance this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]